c'est clair alors il ya toujours
l'opération bouchons là comment ça se
passe exactement dans l'espace sont
également bien alors toujours pareil les
ati bouche on peut y accéder par parent
et par l'e-mail bien sûr par l'internet
www.gout.ch d'amour points comme un
bouchon au pluriel d'amour sans d
apostrophes point coop 1 ou la boîte
postale et
et voilà doit garder on a gardé les
bouchons en plastique du lait nous tous
les déchets de bois sont le bois sont
tous les bouchons de boissons d'aller
alors voilà et donc il renoue leur
achète 500 francs la tonne la grande
nouveauté de cette association c'est que
c'est zéro franc zéro centime de frais
de fonctionnement zéro franc zéro
centime c'est à dire que même la banque
qui s'occupe des toiles qu'elle prend
rien les mecs qui collecte les bouchons
les cds bigarchons j'en ai déjà 160 en
france j'ai centrale bigarchons dans
tous les départements
j'espère que je vais en avoir 300
d'accord et donc cédé mais quand un
local où on peut stocker 10 tonnes de
bouchons sont là le camion vient et les
emmène d'eton cinq mille balles ça fait
à chaque fois et si dominique voynet
elle voulait bien me les mettre dans le
train par exemple le livre when he gets
que je gagnerais 850 boeufs il ya 350
vols de transport
ouais et donc si on les mettait dans le
train donc ça serait bien on a téléphoné
un coup mais on est tombé sur un
deuxième à 28e couteau le charcutier du
petit neveu à dominique voynet qui nous
est dit que c'était pas aussi blancs que
je m'adresse directement à l aile et
pour le train dans quelqu'un ou qu'elle
nous donne des trains pour mettre nos
p'tits bouchons et le pognon et vao et
le pognon il va en achètent des
fauteuils way et on achète des fauteuils
on va faire des bassines des sceaux pour
l'afrique chez les récipients sont très
importants dans rêvé c'est une grosse
cause de mortalité 1 c'est la flotte que
tu fais cinq bornes pour aller chercher
de l'eau je peux les récipients parce
qu'on fait là qu on la boit fallait
cuisine on fait des tatras a fini par
laver les pieds du gamin et on fait un
orphelinat à madagascar pour 60 ghost et
tout ça sans demander de pognon
uniquement demandant aux gens de faire
un petit acte d'ailleurs époux qui est
génial ce qui est bien c'est que c'est
les enfants qui portent cette
association dont je dis à tous les
enfants de france qui pense à toi je
leur fais un gros bisou ce que c'est eux
qui disent non au moment jette pas le
bouchant les enfants sont pas dans le
monde de l'argent tu sais donc c'est un
moyen pour eux de faire un acte tout
d'un coup d'amour puisqu'ils sont pas
dans le monde du pognon et ça permet
même aux riches de données monsieur le
riche ici jamais quaden